I know I say this every morning but
they're not moving if you think it's no
big deal
say something oh my god you think
they're dead too I'll go check don't be
dead
oh you're alive you're alive oh no you
can't just leave guys you gotta tell me
where you're going that food gonna have
some why are you spitting it up but can
I have some no stay right here I'll go
check on everything I know where they
are now everything's fine I'm so hungry
oh I can't wait I can't wait I can't
wait look I'm even doing a trick that's
are hungry I am
faster faster faster wait I can eat this
right this is food it guys I've been
getting some mixed signals lately is
this food not for you buddy is this wood
that's a jacket this has got to be food
right honey are you sure you're sure
this is food oh yeah this is really good
that can't be good
we gotta hide we gotta get out of here
whoa I'm okay why are there clothes on
the floor
why don't they smell like us I can fix
that oh don't panic I'm fine don't worry
about me it's fun please come back
inside
that's not where you go excuse me that's
where you go you go there okay guys
great news I finished cleaning my room
and do a little sushi sushi I've never
seen them fight like this of course just
salads I can't take this and what are we
gonna eat oh my god they're not talking
it's probably over okay we're all
freaked out this is upsetting because I
love both of you but I'm gonna live with
her because we all know I love her more
okay obviously things worked out this is
embarrassing but we all said things we
didn't mean back there right thanks let
me sleep in bed tonight guys you won't
even know I'm here
did you hear that are you awake